you had this conversation you put on
yourself stack uh with jordan uh jordan
peterson
about cognitive inequality i think it's
titled wrestling with cognitive
inequality
this particular topic of
just iq differences between groups
why is this
why is it so dangerous to talk about
why this particular topic
well it's like you're calling black
people inferior it's like you're saying
they're genetically inferior that's what
people are saying it's like you're
rationalizing the disparity of outcomes
by reference to the
intrinsic inferiority of black people if
you if you say cognitive ability matters
for social outcomes if you say cognitive
ability exists
people really are different in terms of
their intellectual functioning and if
you say cognitive ability differences
are
are substantial between racially defined
populations
the sum of that there is cognitive
ability it matters and the difference by
race is the conclusion
that outcome differences by race are in
part due to
natural differences between the
populations
people find that to be
completely offensive and unacceptable
so that's what i think is going on
can you still man that case that we
should be careful doing that kind of
research
so uh
this has to do with research
it's like uh the nazis used
nietzsche
in their propaganda
right
you can use white supremacists could use
conclusions
um cherry-pick conclusions of studies
to uh to push their uh to push their
agenda can you steal a man in the case
that we should be careful yeah i could
do it at three levels one is
what do we mean by cognitive ability so
there's many different kinds of
intelligence a person might say
how good are iq tests at measuring
other kinds of human capacities that are
pertinent to success in life like
temperament
like emotional intelligence and so on so
intelligence is not a one-dimensional
thing measured by g
the
cognitive psychologists talk about g the
general intelligence factor which is a
statistical construction
it's a factor analytic uh resolution of
the
correlation
across individuals in their performance
on a battery a different kind of test
and they
use that to
to define a
general factor of intelligence and a
person could say
that is a very narrow view of what human
mental capacities actually
are and that uh it's much better to
think about multi-dimensional
uh measures of human mental functioning
rather than a single cognitive ability
measure so-called iq
which is a narrow uh construction
that doesn't capture all of the uh
subtle nuance of human difference in
functioning functioning is not just the
ability to
recite backwards a sequence of numbers i
say eight seven nine five three two you
say two three five seven eight nine it's
not just that intelligence is
a
complex
uh management of many different
dimensions of human performance
including
uh uh things like being able to stick
with a task and and not give up
things like being able to discipline and
control your impulses so as to remain
focused and so forth
that could be one dimension i could
start by questioning the very foundation
of the argument
for racial differences in
uh cognitive ability by saying that your
measure of cognitive ability is
uh flawed
i could go to a higher level i could say
what we're really interested in
is
social outcomes and the question of what
factors influence social outcomes
extends well beyond mental ability to
many other things so here's an example
um
visual acuity how well do you see
you're not wearing glasses i am
visual acuity
varies between human beings some people
see better than other people do
visual acuity can be measured
i can put you at the chart and you can
can you identify and read that bottom
line in small print or not so we can
measure visual acuity and it varies
between human beings
visual acuity is partly genetic
i think that's undoubtedly true
we inherit genes that influence whether
or not we are nearsighted or farsighted
or astigmatic or whatever
so visual acuity differs between people
and can be measured and is under genetic
control
on the other hand corrective lenses
allow for us to level the playing field
between people who are differently
endowed in terms of visual acuity
likewise social outcomes are what we're
really interested in employment earnings
whether or not they're law abiding how
do they conduct themselves and their
families and so forth amongst
individuals
yes social outcomes are influenced by
so-called cognitive ability but they're
influenced by many other things as well
if they can if there are interventions
that can be undertaken in society that
level the playing field between people
who have different natural endowments of
cognitive ability
the fact that people or groups differ in
cognitive ability becomes less
significant
just like it's less significant that
people differ with respect to how well
they see when corrective lenses allow
for the leveling of that playing field
there are in fact interventions
educational interventions early
childhood interventions that have been
shown to level the playing field to
create better life outcomes for people
even if they
happen to be endowed with low
intelligence so a second level
of arguing against this whole program of
research on human differences and
intelligence is to observe that yes
human beings and perhaps racially
defined groups may differ on the average
in intellectual endowment but there well
may be social interventions that level
the playing field whether it's in
education or in other kinds of
programmatic interventions especially
for the poor
a final level of argument is the one
that you alluded to which is that if you
talk like this you're going to encourage
a kind of politics which is very ugly
and it's best
to frame the discussion
in ways that don't put emphasis on
racially defined natural differences
between populations
uh that's a argument that i am myself
personally
uh conflicted about
on the one hand i think
you know
those people are just stupid
it is uh racist okay
on the other hand i think
the the calculation we shouldn't do this
kind of research suppose i'm at the
national science foundation a research
team submits a proposal the proposal
proposes to undertake a study the study
would explore the extent to which
people and racial groups differ with
respect to their intellectual
performance and how that's
influenced by their genetic and
environmental interaction and i decide
not to fund the study based on a
political calculation
that the subject is too sensitive
and if you explore that subject you
might get the wrong answer and if you
get the wrong answer the white
supremacist will be encouraged
well that is presuming before the
research is done
that i know the outcome of the research
and that i can calculate what the
political consequence of the research
outcome is going to be
that's that's assuming the thing before
you even know what the thing actually is
it's a kind of omniscience it presumes
that you as the master of the universe
can tell people what it is that people
are being treated like children what it
is that they're capable of knowing and
what it is that they're not capable of
knowing it would be like someone saying
to einstein
i don't know about that special
relativity theory you know it could well
lead to
the development of technologies that
would allow nuclear weapons there's
someone saying that oppenheimer who is a
physicist overseeing the manhattan
project where the u.s developed a
nuclear weapons capacity
don't carry out that project because
the results of acquiring that knowledge
may be more than we can deal with or
someone saying to someone doing
biomedical research who's interested in
exploring
the nature of the human genome
don't carry out that experiment that
cloning undertaking whatever because the
consequences could be
uh deleterious well the consequences
could be deleterious the consequences
could also be the cure of cancer the
consequences could also be being able to
generate electric power without
producing carbon effluent uh so
who are you to tell me who you being
the person in the political position to
control the research
what the consequence of doing the
research is i i think
i don't want to seed
that kind of power to politicians
over the course of of human inquiry
so
yes i would want there to be regulations
governing the use of
biologically sensitive and potentially
dangerous
pathogens in a lab in wuhan
or anyplace else i would i would not
want to simply leave that to laissez
faire
on the other hand i think that the
tendency to try to shut down inquiry
on behalf of supposed adverse political
consequences
is the road to ignorance and uh
impoverishment at the end of the day for
humankind denying ourselves the
potential benefits of that kind of
inquiry i think we need to take our
chances with inquiry rather than to try
to control it and i feel that way about
the exploration of human intelligence
as much as anything else
so you've asked me to still man the case
against
research on iq of the sort that charles
murray is famous for popularizing and
i've said
hey your measure of intelligence is
single dimensional and it ought to be
multi-dimensional
i've said b
the consequences of people's differing
in intelligence depends not only on the
natural endowments of the people but
also on the
uh environment and the potential for
intervening in the environment
environment through one or another kind
of instrument as the metaphorical
example of the use of corrective lenses
to level the playing field between
people with different visual acuity uh
indicates but finally i've said
yes research on racial differences in iq
can foster
um uh political beliefs that we would
regard to be
um
obnoxious
on the other hand to presume that what
we don't know yet and might find out
from the research is going to be harmful
is to assume a kind of
presumption or of knowing what the
outcome of unknown processes might be
which we ought to be very slow to
embrace
because if we had done so in the past we
wouldn't have nuclear power uh there's a
lot of things that we wouldn't know i
mean what were people saying about
darwin and uh exploration of the
evolution and origin of the species they
were afraid that it was gonna in effect
disprove the uh religious-based accounts
of you know
what were they saying about copernicus
and
et cetera et cetera so you know
that was a masterful
layering of uh quote wrestling with the
cognitive inequality he dragged in
nuclear research uh uh copernicus darwin
biomedical research with genetics even
covet and and um
uh the lab leak i mean this that was
that okay that was just fun to listen
you